مشاهدينا مرحبا بكم في مجزره من قناه
الجزيره اعلنت الاداره العسكريه لمدينه
كييف ان قوات الدفاع الجوي اسقطت مسيرات
ملغمه في احدث هجوم روسيا على العاصمه
الاوكرانيه واضافت ان حطام احدى الطائرات
الحق اضرار بمبنيين اداريين في حي
وسط العاصمه
نقل موقع اكسس الاخباريه عن مصادر بان
هناك على الامين العام للامم المتحده
لنشر المفتشين في اوكرانيا للتحقق من
استخدام روسيا للمسيرات ايرانيه الصناعه
فيها هجماتها على كياف ومدن اخرى في وقت
ترفض فيه روسيا ان يتحركين لمجلس الامن في
هذا الاتجاه
انا مسؤولون امريكيون ان واشطا تضع
اللمسات الاخيره على خطط لتزويد اوكرانيا
بالصواريخ الدفاع الجوي في موسكو قال
مسؤولون بالكرملين الى منظومات ستصبح هدفا
مشروعا للقوات المسلحه الروسيه في حاله
تسليمها الى كيس
نقلت صحيفه بوليتكو عن برقيه للخارجيه
الامريكيه ان اداره تواجه صعوبات في تتبع
ماذن المساعدات الماليه والعسكريه التي
تقدم لاوكرانيا واشاره البرقيه الى انها
المسؤولين يلجاون الى كل التقنيات المتاحه
لتتبع النيليارات الدوله
الاوكرانيين لحسب الصحيفه
قال رئيسه حركه حماس يحيى السنوار ان
الحركه تمهل الجانب الاسرائيلي وقتا
محدودا لاتمام صفقه تبادل الاسرى والا
فاستغرق ملف اسرع الاحتلال وتجد سبلا اخرى
لتحرير الاسرى الفلسطينيين على حد تعبيره
وعرضت وحده الظل التابعه لكتاب القسام
الجناح العسكري لحماس عرضت السلاح الجلديه
الاسرائيليه دار جولدن الاسير لدى القسام
منذ عام 2014 وقالت الوحده في كلمه لها
خلال احتفاليه الذكرى الخامسه والثلاثين
لتاسيس الحركه
غنيمه من غنائم عمليه اسر الضابط
الاسرائيلي
في اشاره الى الاتفاق الايطالي الذي وقع
في الخامس من الشهر الجاري في السودان قال
رئيس مجلس السياده في السودان عبد الفتاح
البرهان انه لا تسوى سياسيه هناك بالمعنى
الذي فهمه البعض وشدد على ضروره الا تحاول
اي جهه اختطاف لاتفاق لمصلحتها الذاتيه
كما اكد ان القوات المسلحه لن تقر اي
اتفاق نهائيا ينال من ثوابت البلاد
من جهه قال الناطق باسم الاليه الثلاثيه
وممثله الاتحاد الافريقي بالسودان محمد
بلعيش ان بعض الاطراف في السودان تهدد
باسقاط الحكومه القادمه قبل تشكيلها وحذر
من السماء السياسي
اعلن الرئيس الامريكي خلال منتدى الاعمال
ضمن القمه الامريكيه الافريقيه الاولى من
نوعها في عهده بواسطن عن الصفقات
واستثمارات امريكيه جديده في افريقيا
تعزيز للشراكن سيعرض بيض الدعم الامريكيا
لزياده دور الاتحاد الافريقي يشمل تخصيصات
تمثيل دائما له في مجموعه دول العشرين
وكان وزير الدفاع الامريكيه ابدا قلقه مما
سماهم محاوله الصين وروسيا تعزيزه نفوذهما
في افريقيا واضاف ان الصين توسع وجودها
الاقتصاديه الغامض لممارسه التاثير
السياسي في القاره متهما موسكو وبجين لعدم
الشفافيه
شكلكم واينما كنتم فيها